five identical notes all reading are you  sentient were written and copied by dr  veritas in preparation for the  experiment a note was placed on the  setting fine and produced a note  containing an excerpt from the 1641  treatise meditation on first philosophy  by rene discards in latin it read i am i  exist whenever it is uttered from me or  conceived by the mind necessarily is  true the next note was placed inside on  the setting very fine what emerged was  an excerpt from the essay an essay  concerning human understanding by  philosopher jean locke reading the  source of ideas every man has holy in  himself and though it be not sense as  having nothing to do with external  objects yet it is very like it and might  properly enough be called internal sense